monique martin conseillère
départementale du canton de wintzenheim
nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui à hohrod
à la ferme du versant du soleil les
jeunes agriculteurs qui dynamise la
vallée qui font la vente de produits
locaux qui effectivement développe le
tourisme par l'attractivité de cette
vente
donc je crois que c'est important de les
soutenir au magasin de vente vous
trouverez également lu munster mais du
baril case du csk du beurre des oeufs
production de la ferme du jus de pomme
fabrication maison également donc de
quoi trouver tout ce qui est produits
locaux non ce magasin de vote en plein
centre de munster dans un cadre
magnifique
nous ne retrouvons derrière moi la
maison de retraite
il est vrai que le la population est
vieillissante et donc des initiatives
locales par rapport à favoriser
l'accueil des personnes âgées dans
diverses structures est importante ce
qui est également intéressant c'est les
relations intergénérationnelles ou en
fin de compte la jeunesse rencontrent
les personnes âgées par rapport à des
activités et donc créer des liens et
évite l'isolément
c'est important même au niveau du
conseil départemental qui a
effectivement un rôle important à jouer
dans ce domaine